so Andrew Tiffany you never thought
you'd make it two winners Wednesday no
it's been a it's been a rough year I
even invited John losers on a Tuesday
[Laughter]
mr. Smith's a loser Thursday windows
Wednesday's for people that are winners
and I know you've not felt like a winner
like seriously I've probably felt like a
loser on the property front yeah in
terms of relative suppose people than
the Academy success yeah it's how I've
seen everyone else yeah yeah you know
when you see you see people killing a
property and all the testimonials and
the stories deep it's supposed to be
inspiring do you think there's some
people for some people it's demoralizing
absolutely yeah jealousy and the
aggressive as well if you want to be in
that position and you still quite know
you feel that you do know I think yeah
yeah you follow me have become a winner
or at least what I define is a winner
which is great lot I know you've you've
well you've made nine Grand in the last
three months and you do really well got
joint venture deal that's right yes talk
we'll go on to but it wasn't an easy
journey for you know it took a long time
tech talk us through taught us about the
journey so from the very very start I
started the Academy in this middle of
there and in there and it's like a year
ago now yes a year over yeah that's
right so I joined when we did the deer
finder Shiva guns of course yeah
and as a result going to that class
actually lost my job say you got fired
as a result of going on the DFA correct
that's insane enough in a corporate
world yeah it's just is what it is you
know I expected you on both the doctors
anything it's it's a controversial issue
seems to be so you now in a situation
where you jobless and and you've just
gone into debt because if you remember I
might I might miss remember this but
when you wanted to join the Academy I'm
pretty sure we told you no because we
said you can't afford it you're a loser
no sorry not a loser but what we just
said you know it's it's not it's
probably not the best thing for you to
do and you and you went and got a loan
out to pay for the Train end without we
didn't tell you to do that
Horseman's and then you know you got a
loan out which we didn't even know about
and then you came back and you I think I
remember you showed me the money in the
account unless I've got it now
and then we and then we found out that
you've got a loan and stuff and at that
point you probably thought I'm on the
Academy the Academy yeah I'm with Samuel
who's got the Midas touch he's got the
magic one to success I'm gonna do rent
to rents
I'm gonna kill it I'm gonna make a load
of money and and and you went out and
you did put the effort in
yeah but what happened so initially you
get bombarded with all the strategies
rents are endless options everything so
you just go and cream it you have no
idea what you want to do don't really I
think the time to really bodyweight map
is
and then make it a like a Pokemon Center
strategy - yeah why did was is I took
all information and tried implementing
all that in a parallel whilst working
full-time job yeah not quite as much up
at that point down the line when we went
through
so essentially what took all the
strategies try to implement him just win
how did how did he get wrong
first of all it was just a case of time
management was a massive issue working a
full-time job as a fireman turning
restaurants please you said that's me
before I actually um you saying just a
minute ago that when you didn't have
when you lost your job you don't have
loads of time now but then you got did
you get another job
basically I went to come up to the
course I lost my job and then from that
thoughts myself I watched every ounce
what I knew to be touch elect and he
goes I'm about to find a bigger picture
all the motivation and stuff and it's
quite a common thing across all
malicious we just having a big picture
yeah things waltz into my property I
want to be a pop there I thought that's
about him to be and so I thought I'm
gonna be estate agent so first thing I
do tried to be I had two weeks to find a
job
I was looking month-long for me my
partner II bought place
and sends it down with real stretched
thinking like stretch that stretched
stretched out in death
yeah and you've not got a job one
wanting to get a job as an estate agent
you are on the Academy yeah which is
good yeah then what
so I decided I was gonna try and do
whatever I could see it and what can
happen using skills I've already got
getting this property
I'd already qualified as an electrician
and then what further Tomatis job
Americans take a step back yeah that
will give me access to a power network
access to all the trades again and
meeting with people and essentially work
for myself imagine real time yeah so I
rule my cousin Rob I must watch him for
a long time not really for some that
where fantastic guy really really helped
me I went a bad spot and just like that
walk and everything I said I work three
for one month oh yeah if I'm good Samuel
that's a cool thing to do that's that's
a cool thing to do it was uncomfortable
cuz I knew in that moment I didn't
perform yeah I would have been drunk so
and well that's when I took the job form
really well worked at me on and it's
that subcontracting to him and right now
I've got to look myself got me on some
work completely last time I do really
rational working you see it's all of a
sudden I had this an ounce of fire which
I thought was had enough and sames it
maging the time when scrap price
structurally it's working
18 months and mine at night
yeah it's quite it was the invest a lot
that's always a learning about what you
see - so you're now working for yourself
at that point but you're working more
hours probably for less money exactly
the property thing is just becoming a
dream
yeah you're still trying to do rent
events yeah so the agreement was with my
cousin because he's on the online bank
he would just cover my expenses yeah
and the idea was the rent to run would
then give me an extra income that's
right
which is a great idea yeah but did it
work no why not again
it sang I'm quite sticker for the
numbers the deals one stacking yeah
sometimes it's very ending the thing is
that each one of them pull you on that
because there's a few things if everyone
wasn't there it was an elite legal issue
and you said you almost felt like the
whole serviced accommodation system is
flawed well originally it was read
somebody else was using Katrina Jones's
model right on the rental rents so I
went essentially and bar on her model
first yeah so I looked into it obviously
these let's access between this material
but essential Apple Moss is I really
what's out of that real specific and
then move into and since its foundation
after so with the rent events I know a
lot went wrong yeah what were the key
categories that went wrong so firstly is
the numbers just didn't stack the
numbers weren't stuck into me I was
sliced declare it in terms of I wanted
everything to be very very I wasn't used
to negotiating yeah I was an uber thing
cross he needs to be also so I've taken
that same
not assume what y'all say it's a hundred
percent in to be got to be any
compromise okay and so sometimes the
numbers weren't staffing but sometimes
you felt like you just weren't able to
negotiate with the landlord and he
wasn't drop it yeah it was quite hard to
give you the problem was to work did the
numbers ever work on any of the deals
that you did yeah and then what went
wrong and things were just but it comes
to the landlord over pull out for
whatever reason a lot the time it was
just essentially yeah but the Veals
some reason some reason or and always
you seem to two or three which is good
just drops off did you feel like you
almost had the kiss of death over deals
yeah yeah did you blame yourself did you
blame the system did you blame the
training like what wasn't working
what things I blend I think it's hard to
completely pronounce of one thing though
I had this ideal image
myself doesn't work yeah happened yeah
probably massively regretting the day
that you met me yeah oh the villain
something really right right but I
didn't become the villain at this point
right yeah because because now you think
in I wasn't a pretty bad situation it
but then I came to the crash course I
lost my job I then went into debt to pay
for the Academy which isn't working yeah
and and now I mean a worse off place
than I was
thanks a bunch yeah and you then you
became you know unhappy person really
for a bit yeah so from November a bit
sucks away from property I'm real here I
thought I'm gonna quit I just don't
anything to do with it it's everyone's
it's a dream and it's an academy that's
pretty severe to feel like that yeah and
I'm not very Bacchus myself really no
you didn't go you didn't go round you
know trying to try because there's one
thing having your own dream feel like
it's crushed but then some people take
that and try and crush everyone's dream
yeah it's not work for me therefore I'm
gonna try and crush everyone else's
dream and try and you didn't do that no
but you you just wanted it inwardly took
it and felt you know not depressed but
you're a bit of
right now yeah definitely I was just one
with our fighters winner then I couldn't
see a way of getting back out the
position I was in
yeah but I really need to sort it this
subcontracting to a new level
yeah so basic from November to December
I kind of just let go of everything
squirrel endlessly and just it was just
there the blood spills at that point
this kind of just got real I just met
these emotions of it almost yeah
and came to January Nassau tried rents
around and open of power and other
members and I know it's not a lot of
people doing some of the extra path okay
I think the previously-mentioned so the
head of thought right fantastic driver
in such that getting deals and deals
everywhere aggressor suddenly came to
the point with the couple of deals you
get into signing and came across a and
aspects of the residents of conditions
caused by industry and that's the
mortgage conditions yeah
so essentially more in surrenders I'm
assuming within the industry not
complete the rents rental industry and
not being complete
yeah and in terms of mortgage because
everything that's run in the SD with the
Spencer yeah a lot of people that do
read to rents for sure that they cut
corners yeah and and I know that the way
we teach it we teach you properly yeah
which makes it harder yeah absolutely
mortgage yeah general battle and you
can't retrospective out of rents the
rent model yeah so you've got how are
they get permission you've got to get a
property that's got no mortgage
yes it limits it limits what you can do
Humongousaur then there's also insurance
there's head leaks that you need to
check yeah so you start now hitting your
head off a bit more on the legal problem
yeah and how did that make you feel
yeah just I were just used to at this
point we kind of just felt normal to you
just the lack of success just felt
normal
failing became normal you just became
like this under day outside right okay
here's what it is shocking but it's
Willie because sad to not feel it didn't
hurt like he did in regional okay it
kind of does but then at the same time
every successful person will always have
had failures yeah and if you can't take
failure if you can't take being told no
if you can't take a deal falling throat
you probably shouldn't be in the
business you know you for an Academy
member for sure went through a
considerable or more amount of hardships
and failures but many doh maybe it was a
combination of yeah your time that you
had you could commit to it a bit of luck
I have a few different things I don't
know for sure yeah but but but it was
harder but you've got about to take that
ya threw it now at this point you're now
messaging me sending me threatening not
quite just really arty messages right
yeah yeah like you know oh
do you even know my name you know I'm at
the Academy you know really nice like
like but but you weren't you know you
weren't happy with me at all and up no I
just yeah you felt like you've been
almost like sold a dream left left out
to burn in the desert I think because
everyone's
relative to me he became the course was
a life you know it was like a humongous
stretch yeah so I felt it really half
yeah it wasn't just like a casual dancer
for example for me it felt like anything
this is your yes this is the most money
you've ever spent ever anything and it
has to work and it's not and you're now
feeling desperate and angry and
frustrated and I know you know my advice
to people generally because you know on
the Academy I say this because you're
awesome but sometimes people message me
look on the academy or the Academy or
whatever and they want my help
and I'll say look we've liked it on the
Academy we've got weekly Q&A sessions
we've got monthly coaching calls I've
run the two day accelerated cokes a
little we're gonna come on down you know
and I know you did eventually you came
down to the accelerated coaching and
mentoring program with myself yeah two
days two days yeah pretty intimate yeah
very intimate and how was it yeah that
was then we've skipped quite a bit there
that's what that was quite recently so
that was like yeah but that's when I
know that that was that was where okay
book will go chronological um so now
you're a bit disillusioned
yeah with property in general yeah rent
to rent you're thinking at this point
you don't want to do rent around yeah at
all then what so essentially what
happened that point right I'm just
implementing strategies mindlessly I
need to really evaluate the
circumstances currently where I'm yeah
in girl from strategy from there which
I've not done previously I just
yeah so from there I read by the big
fear for an electrician I work myself
I'm in properties every day doing repo
for I don't have much time because the
irrational work plans
I need something fits in me that so soft
suit came about yeah of course much
times Anita good after it's a capital
want to come Karen doing partition being
electrician and I can use it out to do
work my salsa foxy as well okay fine -
so you basically found because there's
obviously a lot of different strategies
within promote a you've been banging on
with rent Tourette's or way at different
types of renter ants yeah but hounding
renter ants and then you always just
thought actually maybe if I try one of
the other strategies this this could fit
in more with my lifestyle I'm in houses
I know about refurbs maybe I could find
good refurb opportunities but brrrr by
refurbish we find an opportunity I can't
buy myself
I'm absolutely skint but I can put them
up with investors okay so then what so
essentially I got to work for it away on
it I just thought that's the bigger
thing else went all-in thought about
sort of growing but nothing to lose
fantastic let's do this so it's that
sourcing and that's awesome a lot
solvent working as much stuff good and
then ended down time I got any impending
any spare
source and selves view properties view
and just start something deal so near
the original plan was so original I
started currently doing year to plan I
think we start the Academy spend a new
position for multiple years Bacchus
might make sense when your very first up
you got no knowledge every quarrel with
makes much more sense yeah sure it
changes so quick yeah rinse around you
know and then some base plate that's
good to an export plan
so since since then Ned you've found a
property a month yeah and passed it on
and got a fee for it yeah so how did you
you mentioned your electrician so that's
how you're defining properties you're
looking at properties in Leeds yeah how
did you find the investors it's an
interesting one so I actually have no
investable so I'm gonna go first deal
yeah I just got it
what an offering you got accepted I was
like right this is interesting an
investor I've got a deal
I really would like to know if you say
that numbers are unbelievable they
really are because you're one of the
most pessimistic yeah conservative yeah
the content you see yeah that's one of
the reasons why your rent events were so
rubbish was because you looked you did
worst case on every day which is not bad
thing to do but having worst case
glasses on the management fees the
maintenance the the occupancy rates
worst worst worst worst worst worst
worst yeah suddenly a good deal can look
bad awesome so you kind of suck like say
you can't sort yourself off a deal and
yeah how do it in the fossil negative
towards that
but then when you did the stress test on
the vibratory finance deals even worst
case on everything you're still looking
at some really good deals so all the
numbers on the first on the first
property found so the first one was a
what the purchase price was it was
advertised at forty five forty five
thousand yes
how much you get accepted so because he
wanted to cash in one quick sale and
1305 with it just under the assumption
are you okay say thirty nine five
hundred
yeah refurb costs we took cost ten
thousand ten thousand so all in you're
talking 50 thousand 50 thousand and then
how much is the new value new by 68 Wow
my respect this pump that's a good deal
yeah that's like such a good deal how
much you sell that deal for three
thousand is a steal
yeah okay then you do it again the
following month another similar deal yep
similarly a different investor different
Agosta yet another three thousand in
your bank a number three thousand for a
month another day open video no three
thousand in your bank so now now on top
of you electrician job yeah if I don't
even a job because I know you even our
systemized a little bit now it's more
the business yeah still working hard
there's a business yeah good should be
the ideas of a business but on top of
that you've been consistently making
three thousand pound a month profit a
month by by finding good properties make
some massive you now deserve to be a
winner on a Wednesday bro I mean I was
gonna get you one losers on a Tuesday
yeah but look blue books how can i book
you on on winners
I mean losers Tuesday when when you've
been making three grand a month
consistently like that less is that's a
story man that's a story man at this
point though you still hadn't done your
coaching with me which comes towards the
end of the Academy yeah
so we're back on chronological order how
did that go
even though you introduced me to the
idea of using old strategies I still put
I do process down
it really felt angry towards the Academy
in general obviously because that's
about what's say even though you're
making three grand a month from and be
honest with me the stuff that you were
making three grand a month from it was
up because of the Academy but even
though you're making 3 grand a month
part-time because of my training you
still think I'm a dick at this point is
still not a fan
no obviously because it's that inside
there for so long
yeah and it just yeah it's so funny
yeah because at this point I guess
although you would do well now in your
mind yet you still thinking I lost my
job I was in debt off having beans on
toast you know I was almost homeless
because of it you go because of this bad
decision which Samuel told me to do
although I kind of didn't but but but
still I'd still even if hadn't directly
said you should do this you'd been sold
on the idea because of me so you still
got a little bit hatred towards me yeah
what happened on what happened on those
two days just you came and you know
different when you see something isn't
it so you in person you do a really
really good
two days first they're successful at on
the Academy very high you've bet you've
been through it you've seen it I think
as well it's just it's all sort of the
mind the mindset changes just the prices
part yeah not for me personally is there
but you but you saw it as well in that
room there was only one person that
hadn't done a deal and that person who
hasn't in a deal will do it in their
scope democracy it's never small weights
then if you've got all the ammunition
but you've got to turn up yeah because
we can't track success from people
unless they're actually showing up so
actually not I mean you don't show up
then show up with a long face and a
hatred heart like you did
he's still showing up we still got show
up otherwise how can you expect to give
me
taught me a gym member with the best
personal trainer in the world but then
when he turns up to your house not let
them in yeah you got to let the personal
trainer in this again it's the same
thing it's just the emotion of something
camera icon soon still got some look at
the fast
yeah driven by them yeah consumer that
initial worse than I need you react so
when did you turn from Simon's a bit of
dick to actually you know what he's
changed my life for the better and I'm
grateful doesn't know and yet it was
okay enough to see in you the course
yeah two days real he'll not mindset and
you know real real the two years
everything that room like you know every
what's up different yeah actually yeah
you come to the crash course when your
very first there when I was there I just
that's when for me it was like this
which is I think perceptions everything
like you can you can look from your
point of view you could say oh I'm
annoyed because I felt like I was made
out to be easier it was I had hardships
it took me a long time to get but then
from the other oh right well it's like
look the Academy's a 12-month program
I'm now towards the end of the Academy
and I'm making three grand a month on
these deals yeah
I've learnt absolutely bucketloads I've
made loads of friends yeah like
depending on how you look at the side of
the coin depends on whether you're happy
or not absolutely but what what happened
what did i ban you from doing
I didn't ban you from hating me but I
did when I looked over your deals what
did i ban you from doing ever sewn them
again yeah no more selling deals I know
you well still so deals but what's the
what but the your main focus now needs
to be what JB JB
so I was the reason finance
you should be buying them yourself man
yeah agreed you should be binding
yourself if you can find properties for
39 grams that need a 10-grand refurb
that are then going to do where for 65
grams to pass that for 3 grand you're
selling yourself short
yeah so I told you go find a joint
venture and start doing - I want to see
four properties that you've bought
yourself via a joint venture or raising
finance and what happened today you got
a joint venture respect man she's just
which is just massive yeah massive so
what would you advise because I told you
when you came here I said yeah keep this
1 billion percent real yeah you know
like what would your advice be to
someone who was maybe even on the
academy or someone that has given it
their all
they've paid money for training they've
gone and sent the leaflets they've
knocked the doors that they're really
trying and they just feel like they're
not getting anywhere what would your
advice be to them as someone that was
there your cell yeah six months ago yeah
so for me personally obviously I'm not a
big picture let's keep you going
he's the most important yeah however
what I would say to people is is the
patient engaging consistent option and
the most important thing is just be
completely resilient yeah
be mentally strong no matter how you
engage business in action powerful
advice powerful advice my advice are all
of my two panes to that would be a don't
place blame yeah because when used wait
I know but but the thing is when you
stop placing blame yeah I made you your
you're awesome and and you'll see your
journey it's so inspiring and what
you're doing and now your friend now you
know I consider you a friend but I think
when when you do when you place blame on
other people or the economy or the
system it's never gonna work
but when you say you know what if
someone has done it I can do it I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna watch winners
Wednesday and BD motivate I'm gonna say
I'm gonna do the same if I don't get all
I can and I think the second thing you
show up yeah you know
yeah sure people say you got lucky
because you happen to be here you
happened you Andrew you did not get
lucky you put yourself you you for such
a time as this
you said you know what I'm an
electrician I'm gonna use this strategy
that suits where I am yeah you know
that's the most important thing don't do
what everyone else is doing
yes Sookie all lives yeah what's fixing
to be you and which is what you learned
yes you showed up in the training rooms
yeah you should and continue continue is
showing up with with an attitude which
is I can do this
consistent man that's incredible so
super proud yeah
good to be friends and thanks for not
hating me anymore I look forward to
seeing you Kelly man
[Music]